ein xxl politiker horst seehofer
50 jahre csu 28 jahre bundestag zehn
jahre bayerischer ministerpräsident nun
tritt er ab der politische riese bild
blick zurück seehofer ist 20 jahre alt
als seine politische laufbahn beginnt
1969 wird er mitglied der jungen union
1971 tritt er dann in die csu ein anfang
der 80er jahre wird seehofer
bundestagsabgeordneter 89 folgt dann das
erste große amt da ist er 40 jahre alt
die berufung zum staatssekretär
nur drei jahre später wird er 1992
bundesgesundheitsminister unter kanzler
kohl bis zum regierungswechsel 1998
erhält er dieses amt was viele nicht
wissen im jahr 2002 erkrankt seehofer
schwer an einer herzmuskelentzündung die
ihn zwar nicht sein amt aber fast das
leben gekostet hätte nach dem
krankenhausaufenthalt sagt er später
dass er sich wegen der hohen
arbeitsbelastung nicht behandeln lassen
habe doch seehofer kommt zurück in der
großen koalition ist der ab 2005 wie der
bundesminister diesmal für ernährung und
landwirtschaft
dann folgen zehn jahre als
ministerpräsident des freistaates bayern
und gleichzeitig ist er csu-vorsitzender
fast unbemerkt 2012 ist er für vier
wochen sogar bundespräsident als
christian wulff zurücktritt führt er die
geschäfte sein letztes großes amt
bundesinnenminister in merkels viertem
kabinett bis zu dieser woche ist
seehofer deutschlands dienstältester
minister und hat gestern am 26 oktober
2021 seine entlassungsurkunde erhalten
politik ist jeden tag ein spießrutenlauf
sagt horst seehofer wie er das 50 jahre
durchgehalten hat und was er nun ohne
diesen spießrutenlauf macht darüber
spricht er jetzt bei bild live
was geht ihnen durch den kopf wenn sie
die bilder sehen ein kompliment für bild
das stimmt alles
und welcher horst seehofer den wir da
gesehen haben war der beste für
deutschland
man kann da kein amt besonders
herausheben es war jedes amtsjahr
anspruchsvoll vom gesundheitsminister
über landwirtschaftsminister ich kann
mich noch an meine rede im bundestag
erinnern meine erste rede als
landwirtschaftsminister war ja
ungewöhnlich für einen
städtischen politiker da kam der ruf
weißt du eigentlich wie eine kuh von
hinten aussieht das hatte ganz still im
bundestag natürlich zu einem großen
gelächter geführt und es war dann auch
sehr anspruchsvoll und
ministerpräsident war mit das schönste
strauß sagt ja immer nach dem papst das
schönste amt auf der welt weil man sehr
viel der bevölkerung begegnet also ich
will jetzt gar keine wertungen vor die
können sich noch einigen allerersten job
erinnern und meinen vor der politik der
einstieg ins berufsleben ja ja ich war
dienst anhänger die waren total
verwaltung in ingolstadt
besoldungsgruppe a eines ja das ist die
flexibelste wissen wieviel dem ikt das
war ich habe jetzt erst einmal begonnen
aufzuräumen zu hause das waren 150 d
mark
und wissen sie noch was ich davon
gekauft haben ja ich habe dann einen
kredit aufgenommen um einen vw käfer
zu kaufen und habt ihr dann abgestottert
jetzt sind sie seit gestern nur noch
geschäftsführend im amt das bedeutet sie
dürfen keine grundlegenden
entscheidungen mehr treffen was machen
sie einen ganzen tag
schauen sie ich bin an der spitze des
innenministeriums dazu gehören 80.000
beschäftigte 20 nachgeordnete behörden
wichtige behörden wie verfassungsschutz
bundespolizei
und sie glauben sich ein solcher apparat
ist ständige bewegung aber keine
grundlegenden entscheidungen mehr
bedeutet ja in so wichtigen fragen wie
grenzkontrollen migrationspolitik tritt
jetzt so eine phase ohne große handlung
ein wie sehr schränkt das die kraft des
innenministeriums ein ja sehr stark
darum hoffe ich ja dass die
verhandlungen jetzt über der
ampelkoalition in der tat noch im
dezember den kanzler wählen dann stehen
aber trotzdem dann zwei monate in denen
im grunde
ist sie recht optimistisches
pessimistisch bis der kanzler gewählt
ist vielleicht fünf wochen aber wichtig
wäre dass die neue regierung bald
zustande kommt denn gerade in meinem
bereich von der inneren sicherheit bis
zur migration stehen sehr sehr große
aufgaben an wir haben nicht nur klima
sondern wir haben große große nationale
und internationale probleme zu lösen wir
hatten vor zwei tagen zum ersten mal
seit vielen jahren am tag 1 über 1000
zuwanderer wenn sie das mal auf den
monat hoch erinnern dann wissen sie dass
dringender handlungsbedarf nach rechtes
mal aufs jahr hoch sind 300.000 ich sage
ich will reinigen der tausch wieder in
das lied dabei bleibt jetzt ist wir
müssen sie kennen der meinung die sieben
minister der sozusagen sie ihre
abschieds tournee macht nicht weil das
nicht kann sondern weil er nicht mehr
darf das ja macht mir irgendwie ein
bisschen sage das wirkt wie so ein
politischer mehltau und eine wahnsinnig
wichtigen phase ja wenn sich das
fortsetzen sollte die zahl die ich
gerade genannt habe dann müsste man mit
denjenigen
die künftig regieren mal kontakt
aufnehmen was wir noch tun können damit
die zahl nicht die explodierende für sie
persönlich aber auch bedeuten dass der
viel zitierte kontrollverlust denen es
mal gab an den grenzen denen sie wo sie
im stande waren den sozusagen aus dem
spiel zu nehmen die dinge zu ordnen am
ende ihrer amtszeit sozusagen wieder da
ist ja wir haben jetzt keinen kontrollen
verlust wir hatten 1000 leute am tag
kommen ist kein kontrollen langsam stolz
wir hatten bis ende september
80.000 das ist in deutschland
das ist ungefähr die größenordnung die
wir immer hatten in den letzten 30
jahren seit der deutschen einheit
manchmal liegt es trüber manchmal
drunter und in manchen jahren wie 215
weit darüber ich sage ihnen jetzt eine
aktuelle habe ihnen eine aktuelle zahl
gesagt die zusammen kommt aus allen
himmelsrichtungen
über die kanarischen inseln über die
balkanroute
schritten herüber stellen so das hat
sich jetzt entwickelt das war zum
beispiel in der wahlkampfzeit überhaupt
nicht absehbar das hat sich jetzt
entwickelt weil die menschen waren ja
schon unterwegs also das heißt wir sind
ja nicht wenn wir nachts plötzlich in
polen yamaha unterwegs sind mal keine
spionage teams sind kroatien sind sehr
ich über dieses sehr ruhig wird es nicht
spielen lassen sondern kluge aufklärung
dass man weiß was man weiß was auf einen
zukommt ja aber wissen sie die
diejenigen die da geschäfte machen das
sind ja meistens geschleusten personen
die
sind auch sehr raffiniert aber wenn ich
jetzt noch mal zusammenfassen wir haben
uns ja mal geeinigt glaube ich auf
200.000 menschen im jahr maximal das
wort obergrenze war dann irgendwie
umstritten und wir brauchen aber 200.000
ist sozusagen die obergrenze weil es
verträglich ist für die integration ist
wenn es aber so weiter geht wie es jetzt
ist es mindestens 300.000 das senkt also
diese obergrenze das ist jetzt ihre
hochrechnung
druck sage ja wenn wenn wir absehen
herzlich in den nächsten tagen und
wochen
das ist eine dauer zuwanderung dann
müsste ich auch als geschäftsführender
minister noch mal mit den fraktionen des
deutschen bundestages kontakt aufnehmen
was wir noch jetzt machen können und
müssen was raten sie der ampel in dieser
frage was ist ihr konkreter vorschlag
was muss der nächste innenminister der
ja nicht nur nicht was seehofer sein
kann sondern auch kein politiker der
union mehr sein kann nach lage der dinge
was muss der nächste innenminister der
innenminister der an in dieser frage
sofort machen und dann richtig machen
die lösung des migrations problems wird
nur gelingen über die europäische union
über eine europäische lösung mit den
drei ansätzen die wir verfolgt haben
aber leider in der eu bisher nicht
durchsetzen konnten in den ländern zu
helfen woher die flüchtlinge gekommen
damit sie keinen grund haben zu flüchten
zweitens an der außengrenze der
europäischen union zu prüfen wer hat
überhaupt ein recht ein anderer auf asyl
zu bestellen diejenigen die kennen kein
recht haben sofort wieder zurück und die
anderen mit einem rechtsstaatlichen
verfahren durchzuführen und dann in
europa zu verteilen das wäre die beste
lösung wenn da ist aber die europäische
union bisher einfach nicht aktiv gibt es
wäre das wäre mein punkt wenn man eine
gute lösung hat wo man den anderen
steigen partner braucht aber der macht
nicht mit dann brauchen wir eine andere
lösung so ja dann bleibt wie jetzt in
polen mit belarus dass die polin die an
der außengrenze europas ligen ihrerseits
eine starke grenzsicherung machen ich
sage ja auch heute noch mal aus der
ministerpräsident kretschmann von
sachsen kürzlich gesagt hat
ich unterstütze die polen bei der
sicherung ihrer grenzen auch mit
befestigungsanlagen weil sie mit dieser
langen grenze sonst nicht fertig werden
wenn das un sanktionen gegenüber belarus
sanktionen gegenüber fluggesellschaften
die die menschen nach menz gepflegt wenn
das auch alles nichts nutzt was er
sinnvollste wäre wenn die eu nicht tätig
wird dank dann müssen wir auch die
deutsch polnische grenze in den blick
nehmen das war ja mal eine diskussion
die ist 218 schon geführt habe aber das
ist die ultima ratio jetzt ist es aber
ja so dass möglicherweise ein grüner
innenminister ins amt kommt die grünen
stehen in vielen punkten ungefähr für
das gegenteil von dem was sie in der
politik vertreten haben glauben sie dass
ein grüner innenminister das so umsetzen
wird die politik der vernunft da geht es
ja eher um einwanderung viele menschen
sollen kommen keiner soll irgendwann
eine grenze abgewiesen werden das alles
hörig und es macht mir sorge wenn ich
darüber nachdenke dass es zu politik
wird was macht es mit ihnen es geht
immerhin auch um ihr politisches
ergebnis um ihr politisches lebenswerk
na gut wir sind wohl in der opposition
und wir müssen dann als opposition eben
unsere konzepte dagegen stellen das ist
ganz ganz wichtig da die
bundestagsfraktion von cdu und sie so
eine ganz wichtige funktion
aber ich prophezeie ihnen dass die
grünen sich auch der realität stellen
müssen und werden denn kein land auf
dieser erde kann unbegrenzt zuwanderer
auf glauben sie dass ein grüner
innenminister harbeck
grenzkontrollen zu polen
eine mauer an den polnischen grenzen das
dass die politik ist die in grüner
wirklich vertritt ja dann muss eben die
politische auseinandersetzung darüber
stattfinden den vorschlag den der bisher
macht der ist ja putzig würde ich mal
sagen wenn er sagt wir sollen die
flüchtlinge die aus belarus kommen
einfach in europa verteilen das wäre die
große genugtuung für lukaschenko denn
wenn der reis alle die über die grenze
bringt über die schleusung und über die
staatliche unterstützung ist eine
staatliche schleusung die da stattfindet
alle die über die grenze bringt wird die
eu in europa verteilen ist es doch ganz
logisch dass er noch mehr über die
grenze befördern wird um die stabilität
in europa zu gefährden das ist kein
vorschlag der praktikabel ist aber ich
sage ihnen voraus nochmal zum zweiten
mal die grünen werden sich dieser
realität stellen müssen und sie werden
ihr nicht ausweichen können weil sie
sonst ja in der bevölkerung
ja sehr stark an vertrauen verlieren
werden die bevölkerung will ordnung
eine gesteuerte zuwanderung die wir
vertragen in der bundesrepublik
deutschland im hinblick auf die
arbeitsplätze auf die wohnungen auf die
integration und sie will auch humanität
ich habe zum beispiel die jetzt noch
geschäftsführend die regierung viele
zeichen der humanität gesetzt nach dem
brand auf griechenland haben wir 3000
kinder aufgenommen als beispiel und
familien also wenn sie die zuwanderung
steuern können sie auch starke signale
der humanität setzen glauben sie dass
die grünen so wie sie jetzt wahrnehmen
für diesen schritt sich den
gegebenheiten zu stellen genug
vaterlandsliebe aufbringen
vaterlandsliebe ist ja das was man in
der politik braucht um ein amt für die
eigenen leute sozusagen ausüben zu
können oder irre ich mich
bis jetzt
würde ich das noch nicht als gegeben
ansehen bei den grünen ein gesunder
patriotismus
das hat nichts mit nationalismus zu tun
ein gesunder patriotismus eine liebe zu
den menschen die in unserem land leben
ob sie jetzt zugezogen sind integriert
sind ob sie hier geboren sind gehört
zwingend zu einer erfolgreichen politik
dazu wenn sie eine politik die sie nicht
mit dem herzen machen die wird nicht
gelingen und deshalb werden die grünen
der
vernunft und der realität nicht
ausweichen können da bin ich ziemlich
sicher ich würde sie ihnen vorschlagen
auch wenn ich jetzt
loslasse von der politik dass sie mich
irgendwann mal nach einem gewissen
zeitablauf einladen dann können wir
diese frage noch mal bilanzieren
außerdem
kenne ich den möglichen künftigen
bundeskanzler olaf scholz sehr gut wir
haben zusammen gearbeitet wir noch
regierender bürgermeister war ich
ministerpräsident
wir haben der bundesregierung manchen
euro aus der hergezogen mainz haben und
jetzt auch als finanzminister und
ich glaube und vertraue da auch auf den
olaf scholz wenn er denn zum kanzler
gewählt wird dass er hier der vernunft
zum durchbruch verhilft
robert habeck ein guter innenminister
ich weiß nicht ob er sich dafür
interessiert ist antwort genug ich wäre
ein ich hab ich habe ihn erlebt
vor vier jahren 2017
in den verhandlungen die wir geführt
haben und
genauso wie die frau berbalk habe ich
sie als beide als sehr sehr sachkundigen
verhandler erlebt es ist ja nicht an den
grünen gescheitert 217 sondern an der
fdp nicht erinnere mich dunkel wir
blicken einmal auf die union und haben
ein kleines geschenk für sie mitgebracht
nämlich eine ganz besondere kasse eine
schwarze kasse das ist beim politiker
immerhin noch besser als schwarze kassen
schwarze taste da ist sie die ist
deshalb ganz besonders weil da
draufsteht alles wird gut haben sie
schon mal gesehen kennen sie dich mein
okay und jetzt nicht dass jemand sagt
wir werden um gastlich gibt es einen
schluck kaffee und dann ist aber es ist
es ist
absolut happy und jetzt sehen sie mal
mit uns zusammen was mit der tasse
passiert die ändert jetzt nämlich ihren
verlauf und da kommt raus alles wird gut
bundestagswahl 2021 der 26 september das
macht diese tasse das war ein wahlkampf
ja wie soll man sagen
artikel der csu eine idee von markus
söder der auf die idee gekommen ist dass
alles gut wird jetzt ist da ja dass du
so schwarz geht weg wird weil es mir
gefällt alles was originell ist was zum
ersten mal jetzt ist aber ja am 26
september sozusagen gar nichts gut
geworden sondern eher schlecht und wenn
man in die analyse geht hört man
natürlich kanzlerkandidat hat die
hauptverantwortung wie viel
verantwortung liegt dann bei der csu und
beim csu-chef
als das muss ich aus ihrer sicht mit
einer floskel antworten jetzt werde ich
habe nicht zu lassen sie können
versuchen
so wie man wahlen gemeinsam gewinnt
verliert man sie auch gemeinsam ich
natürlich hat ein spitzenkandidat wie
mit laschet immer eine
hauptverantwortung
aber wir haben gemeinsam cdu und csu
einen verkorksten wahlkampf geführt das
kann man nicht bestreiten wenn wir
gemeinsam und ja auch gut den wahlkampf
geführt hätten hätten wir nach meiner
festen überzeugung die stärkste fraktion
werden können der abstand war gerade mal
eineinhalb prozentpünktchen das hätten
wir geholt und dass dies durch
uneinigkeit und
ja kein kein optimales programm ja und
ein richtiges ergebnis hat kann ja
beiden immer oder aus dem süden söder
gegen laschet laschet gegen südafrika
weniger es war er immer wieder gegen die
uneinigkeit ja beschrieben aber sie
werden mich jetzt nicht in die lage
drängen dass ich jetzt persönlich diesen
oder jenen an den pranger stelle es ist
eine gemeinsame niederlage da ist die
cdu genauso beteiligt wie die csu und
wir müssen
vernünftig daraus die konsequenzen
ziehen sonst wird's nicht gut auf das
nächste mal nicht das heißt aber der
gedanke dass mit microsoft an der spitze
die union den kanzler stellen würde ist
schon einer der ihnen nahe ist ja gut
wir haben hier zwei mal in der
geschichte der republik den
kanzlerkandidaten gestellt wenn wir die
wahlergebnisse jetzt wieder erreichen
würden die diese beiden
kanzlerkandidaten der csu erreicht haben
dann werden wir wahrscheinlich die
glücklichste und beste parteien ganz
europa also was strauß und stoiber
erreicht haben stoiber 2002 strauß 1980
ist seitdem nicht mehr erreicht worden
und jedenfalls aus der sicht der csu und
deshalb war das nie verkehrt aber
natürlich hat ein csu-mann immer im
herzen den geheimen wunsch dass wir auch
mal den kanzler stellen den wunsch würde
ich auch nie auf gleichsam mit microsoft
hätte es klappen können der satz das
fällt ihnen schwer
ich teile ihnen auch nicht ich sagt
microsoft hätte es auch nicht geklappt
heißt das wissen sie wenn wenn sie
kanzlerkandidat sind dann werden sie
genauso entblättert und
durchleuchtet wie das bei harburg
geschehen ist wie es bei amen laschet
dumm kann man das jetzt überhaupt nicht
zum maßstab machen weil wir nicht wissen
was alles geschehen wäre
und deshalb halte ich die these wenn
markus söder kanzlerkandidat gewesen
wäre dann wäre alles besser gelaufen für
nicht nachvollziehbar ich sage ihnen wir
hätten auch mit armin laschet bei einem
geschlossenen wahlkampf die stärkste
fraktion werden können wir hätten nicht
mehr die alten wahlergebnisse erreicht
das ist aber glaube ich nach 16 jahren
regierung nicht so ganz überraschend da
wollen viele leute auch einen wechsel
aber wir hätten stärkste fraktion werden
können aber das ist jetzt schnee von
gestern schauen wir uns jetzt schauen
wir jetzt schauen wir heute die leute im
land sind immer noch von von corona
sozusagen bewegt wie gehen wir damit um
jetzt jetzt geht es ja in die richtung
die ampel will die sogenannte
epidemische lage nicht entspannen will
sie auch nicht mehr ist tatsächlich hat
ist auch wieder jedenfalls eigenartig
ist eine eigenartige diskussion die wir
uns immer wieder leisten entscheidend
ist sind doch nicht die begriffe und
irgendwelche
grundlagen dahinter sondern entscheidend
ist wir haben mit einem potentiell
tödlichen virus zu tun mit einem sehr
gefährlichen und ansteckenden und auf
mutierenden virus und da ist doch viel
wichtiger was müssen wir tun damit wir
uns davor schützen und das was ich jetzt
heute in den nachrichten gehört habe mit
der maske mit dem abstand mit der 3g mit
der jene die jetzt gar nicht mehr so
diskutiert wird hände sich zu waschen
und zu desinfizieren
das ist doch das entscheidende dass wir
die leute überzeugen es macht sinn eine
maske zu tragen es macht nach wie vor
sinn abstand zu halten es macht nach wie
vor sinn sich impfen zu lassen die
hauptwaffe ist ja die impfung auch wenn
es im durch brüche gibt aber die impf
durch brühe verlaufen in aller regel
milder also ich kann nur alle auffordern
einschließlich joschi mich
überlegen sie sich nochmal und lassen
sie sich impfen sie sind eine
persönlichkeit mit vorbild charakter und
wenn sie sich impfen lassen werden auch
andere menschen sagen da kann dann mache
ich es auch aber ich würde niemanden an
den pranger stellen wenn er sich auch
persönlich überzeugen lassen sich nicht
impfen lässt
und dann gelesen ich bin beides übrigens
ich war auch infiziert bin ob es gott
sei dank überstand oder getestet neben
den anderen sicherheitsregeln die
brauchen wir uns dahinter eine
pandemische lage definiert wird oder
nicht verstanden jetzt haben wir heute
93.000 neuinfektionen das ist schon
gigantisch jetzt bleiben wir noch einmal
ganz kurz für eine schnelle schlussrunde
bei einer frau die ganz wichtig in ihrem
leben ist nämlich angela merkel wenn ich
mir ihre beziehung sozusagen angucke
würde ich sagen hassliebe trifft das
nein oder pack schlägt sich pack
verträgt sich das auch nicht sondern
freundschaftlich freundschaft ist er mit
ihr in kontakt ich habe mich gestern
noch einmal abschließend mit ihr
unterhalten unter vier augen das haben
wir in jeder sitzungswoche halbe stunde
getan wir haben auch noch mal im
schnelldurchgang unsere jahre
gemeinsamen jahres in der 30
revue passieren lassen in diesen 30
jahren hatten wir zwei drei diskussionen
und zwar nicht indem wir uns gegenseitig
herabgesetzt haben sondern bei den
flüchtlingen was ist sinnvoll an
zuwanderung bei der kopfpauschale über
wie soll die krankenversicherung
finanziert werden nach persönliche
leistungsfähigkeit oder jeder zahlt den
gleichen beitrag und dann nochmal 2018
mit dieser grenzkontrolle gegenüber
österreich aber das ist immer so geführt
worden dass wir nach dieser diskussion
ohne dass wir uns vorstellen mussten
ganz vernünftig und professionell
zusammengearbeitet haben und vielleicht
ist der beste beleg herrscht und das
nachdem ich abschied genommen hatte oder
der sich abgezeichnet in münchen
als ministerpräsident und
parteivorsitzender sie mich gefragt hat
kann ich mit dir rechnen sollte es diese
frage stellt ja ein mensch der froh ist
wenn eine zieht und ich hatte das
gleiche empfinden ich war 68 jahre da
könnte man auch sagen es reicht aber
diese frage hat mich dann doch noch mal
zum nachdenken gebracht ich wusste was
ich meine aufgabe das ist bisher das
schwierigste job den ich gemacht habe
und das zeigt unser verhältnis wir haben
in diesen vier jahren
weitestgehend unfallfrei
zusammengearbeitet und wir haben
vereinbart dass wir die kontakte nicht
abbrechen lassen sondern weiter in
kontakt bleiben ich habe noch
dreieinhalb ganz kurze fragen aber
wirklich beziehungsweise die fragen sind
kurz die antworten müssen was nehmen sie
aus dem ministerium wenn die kisten
gepackt sind mit nach hause und stellen
sich in die vitrine
alle persönlichen dinge zum beispiel die
entlassungsurkunde von gestern
können sie eigentlich noch selber auto
fahren ja ich werde sie nicht weil ich
sie nicht zutrauen würde da ist so
langer zeit mit schach ja wenn ich nicht
mal einen offiziellen chauffeur hat habe
ist dass bis jetzt immerhin privaten
dingen meine frau gewesen
ich kann sicher auto fahren aber ich
müsste mich darauf besinnen du bist es
jetzt der fährt also wenn die ampel rot
ist dass ich das jetzt muss ich bremsen
während ich jetzt im auto sitze und weiß
ein anderer besser klingt so als müssten
sie nummer fünf stunden in der
fahrschule machen bevor es losgeht ja
ich werde mit meiner frau trainiert
vergleichbar da geht es mehr um das
konzentrieren wie jeder fahrer sich oder
die fahrerin sich konzentrieren muss ich
habe gerade meinem vater gesagt auf der
fahrt hierher mit
radfahren die kreuz und quer auf der
straße fahren autos die vorteile
verschaffen wollen aber wie gesagt
mensch in berlin auto zu fahren ist
wirklich eine höhere kunst also bleiben
sie in ingolstadt kann ich kann uns
allen wünschen dass teuer sind in
ingolstadt werden die wahlkampfauftritte
machen zum beispiel im wahlkampf der csu
wenn es wieder um die landtagswahlen
geht nicht halten sich aus denn der
microsoft ich brauche dich kann ich auf
dich zählen wenn der markus söder das
sagt das was angela nagy aufhören dann
müssen sie loslassen so das halbe ich
bin da einer der eine lange erfahrung
hat und ich weiß alles besser als alle
anderen das ist falsch ich habe auch in
diesem wahlkampf so gut wie keinen
wahlkampf geführt weil ich glaube die
leute wollen doch gesichter der zukunft
sehen und
nicht der vergangenheit die die sagen
das ist schön aber jetzt gehst nach
hause und lebst noch hoffentlich paar
nette jahre die leute wollen doch frauen
und männer jetzt sehen von denen sie
wissen die sind jetzt für unsere zukunft
zuständig und horst seehofer als sie den
csu vorsitz abgegeben haben haben sie
finde ich also viele wichtige dinge
gesagt aber für mich eines der
wichtigsten zitate uns der berührendsten
gegeben die haben nämlich den anderen
den jüngeren den neuen im amt
hinterlassen vergesst mir die kleinen
leute nicht was ist ihr satz heute am
tag eins nach der ära als in österreich
nach der verlorenen wahl
gibt es keinen besseren satz als den zu
wiederholen vergesst mir die kleinen
leute nicht wenn wir 1,4 millionen
stimmen an die spd verlieren wie ich
glaube aus sozialpolitischen gründen
rente miete familie
dann haben wir dieses feld unzureichend
bearbeitet und auch keine gesichter mehr
wenn sie mal an die zeit von blüm und
geißler ich will dass die vergangenheit
nicht verkehren aber wir brauchen wieder
typen
leute die um eine richtige idee kämpfen
die nicht gleich wieder einknicken wenn
mal die höhere partei ebene sagt sie mal
ruhig und das fehlt uns zum beispiel in
der sozialpolitik und das hat uns auch
im wahlkampf gefehlt vielen dank horst
seehofer ein schlusswort aber noch nicht
ganz ich würde ihnen gerne diese beiden
tassen schenken die wird wieder schwarz
und eine route also in erinnerung an
große großartige große koalition und
natürlich auch mit dem gedanken dass in
der zeit die jetzt kommt niemand mehr
auf die idee kommen soll jemals zu sagen
wir seehofer hat nicht alle tassen im
schrank schön dass sie da waren ich
danke auch wie immer kann man ihren
schlussworten nichts besseres hinzufügen